australia is one of our oldest allies
you know we fought alongside each other
the first second world war
in the korean war
they are a very deep
and trusted partner of both the united
kingdom and the united states and indeed
form one of the core nations of the five
eyes which also adds new zealand and
canada to it
so it was a natural choice i think for
the australians that when they decided
to shift from
diesel electric submarine capability to
uh finding a requirement that matched
their need for a long
deep capable capability in sub-sea
warfare that they would go to that
trusted partner because
you know the secrets of nuclear
propulsion are very secret they're very
uh special and therefore you need to
share that with certain partners you can
trust and that was clearly what was
partly in their mind when they
approached us back in march but can we
just be clear as to to part of the
purpose of this china was not explicitly
mentioned by any of the
the the head of gov either of the heads
of government or the head of state that
they were speaking yesterday but clearly
nuclear-powered submarines their ability
to remain at sea remain underwater there
is a surveillance capacity that is going
to be used and it will be directed at
least in part towards china we have to
assume well i think it will be directed
lots of different threats i mean the
reality is that at the moment australia
has deed electric collins-class
submarines a diesel submarine is
brilliant they're very quiet but what
they do have to do is what we call snort
or snorkel to recharge their batteries
you have to put up a mast effectively
and beca and can be detected therefore
quite easily at certain periods of their
sort of cycle so while they can stay
underwater if they don't move at all for
long periods eventually they will have
to come up if they're transiting or
moving and that would make them very
very easy to detect by big powers who've
invested in that type of surveillance
a nuclear submarine can submerge for
months on end without surfacing at all
and that allows them to have longer
patrols to further afield but also to
keep any adversary getting and i think
that's also important i mean again
you you didn't explicitly mention the
chinese we can say however the chinese
are taking this as a direct slight they
are livid but interestingly you know the
french are also livid about this you
know literally one of our closest allies
they did have the contract to build the
submarines for the australians i'm just
just wondering how wise it is to annoy
the french at the time that we are in
essence relying on them to police those
beaches in northern france and try and
stop the the flow of migrants well look
this is not about us sort of you know we
didn't go fishing for these
opportunities this was a fundamental
australians took a decision they wanted
a different capability in that you can
see both the chinese and the french are
annoyed about this look the french were
contracted to deliver a diesel a
submarine i think when the australians
took a decision they wanted to switch
out of that and into nuclear
that that opened up for them different
opportunities and they clearly made that
choice and of course each country has to
make those choices in its own national
security interests and and they have
taken that decision look we we have no
intention of doing anything to
antagonize the french the french are
some of our closest military allies in
europe we are sizable and comparable
forces and we do things together in west
africa we are we are together we are
providing chinook squadrons to help them
in their counter-terrorism fight i get
on extremely well with my french
counterpart only recently myself in the
foreign secretary went to visit them in
paris and will continue to work we have
common interests both in the pacific and
here at home well the foreign secretary
now of course of course the justice
secretary which it gives me an
appropriate segue into to the reshuffle
action that took place yesterday before
we get into the specifics of it what was
the purpose of this reshuffle was it was
it simply to get rid of some dead wood i
think it was two things the prime
minister wanted to bring forward
a number of women mps who you know he is
determined to both level up not only in
the country but also in in my party's
representation around the cabinet table
and i think it's really important you
bring on talent and i think he was
determined to do that and we had some
fantastic people on our back benches who
who need a time in government and i
think that is important now you you
don't do that in a one-hour you know
like me i've served every rank in
government from the most junior all the
way through to the cabinet over time and
i think it's important to get experience
under the belt so i think once you start
doing that once you start effectively uh
changing the pack of cards the pack of
cards inevitably needs to be re-dealt or
reshuffled
and that's what happens but you look at
some of the people that were leaving i
mean you're not telling me that gavin
williamson was sacked because he was too
competent that he was showing everyone
else and cabinet up look
the prime minister has obviously lots of
reasons why he he reshuffles cabinets
but look fundamentally a lot of my
colleagues gavin has done actually a
fantastic job for fe colleges you know i
in my constituency in preston and
lancaster we have lots of fe colleges
and you know gavin really believes in fe
colleges and i think they've often been
a cinderella part of the education
sector so you know i think it's unfair
to say that about gavin i think what
what happens to all of us and it will
happen to me because that is the nature
of the politics we're in is eventually
the prime minister says i want to make
rey for somebody else and and as a
result you move on there have been some
eyebrows raised over some of the
appointments and it does appear that
once again the prime minister is perhaps
rewarding loyalty rather than selecting
the most competent people for for the
job i mean the dean doris for example i
mean with respect what does nadine
norris know about culture media and or
sport well i think nadine doris is
actually a record-breaking uh well she's
a she's a best-selling author uh you
know uh if that isn't part of the
culture i i couldn't even begin to write
a chapter that a book let alone but uh
well
took herself uh when she was an mp and
decided she was going to be an author
she's sold thousands and thousands of
books and now if that isn't part of
culture medium sport i don't know what's
great about nadine is she produces a
culture that people buy and actually
want to see rather than some of the more
crackpot uh schemes we've seen being
funded in the past by taxpayers money i
think one was on a program not so long
ago about uh
something about 911 and i i think you
know so she'll bring probably realism to
it but she's also from my part of the
world she's from the northwest she's a
she's a great solid and competent uh uh
capable minister and i think she'll be
great she also voted against gay
marriage i don't know if nadine doris
has spent much time in theater land well
look look i think you know as you know
cultural municipal is a very very broad
range
of of industry it's vast uh it's not
just you know 24-hour news here we are
sitting here links all the way through
to to obviously uh in a
theatrical performances but i i think
nadine will be a great secretary of
state
and and i think the other thing we
should remember is you know secretary of
state are there to deliver the
government's agenda and along the
manifesto they're there to get their
departments in line to live within their
means and deliver it and and you know
dcms is a very important growing sector
and nadine will be able to deliver that
clearly you do you do not want to
badmouth any of your colleagues i wonder
if you might make an exception dominic
grab you didn't shed any tears over him
leaving the rco look dominic has been
quoted saying he's delighted to go to
the ministry of justice he you know he
is a lawyer by trade and and what what i
would say is you know i i started my
sort of working career as a soldier and
there is nothing better than being part
of a department on a subject you know a
lot about that you're part of
and that you feel you can contribute to
and i think dominic's you know all my
dealings with him in the foreign office
and and you know he has had some great
successes in the front office he he led
you know the integrated review and
helped deliver that which was bringing
together uh both international aid etc
dominic understands the law and that's
you know pretty important if you're
going to be the lord chancellor of this
country but don't don't tell me you and
your colleagues at the main building of
the ministry of defense were not annoyed
when presumably you were all pulling
all-nighters preparing to send service
men and women out to afghanistan to to
to get people out of the country whilst
he was sitting in a sign language look i
i think that's unfair look what what we
were all focused on is doing a job he
was focused on doing his job and as you
saw the military deployed to afghanistan
in very very difficult circumstances we
haven't given up on that you know let's
not forget there are in in my area in
the arab there's some 240
people 60 people are still there that we
are working to get out the country over
40 have made it into third countries
with their families and we're starting
to repatriate them look it was a big
operation uh dominic and the foreign
office did some amazing things some of
their officials were out there alongside
ours and i think you know we shouldn't
reduce this to to where someone was on
the night of a friday night i think the
reality was uh it was a challenge for
the whole international community and we
delivered that i do want to spend a good
bit of time again on our up in just a
second but but perhaps that you know liz
trusts by my reckoning is the fifth
foreign secretary since nazim zagari
radcliffe was taken into custody by the
iranians what hope is there that she
will be the foreign secretary that
finally sorts that mess out well i think
your question is best i'm afraid
directed at the iranians on that you
know we have been trying at all levels
to to
get her release and others who are also
held by the iranian government there's
been a change of government in tehran
we have tried lots and lots of methods
that is ongoing we are still trying to
deliver that that will take the whole
the whole of government to deliver uh
one thing i can tell you about liz liz
liz has successfully concluded dozens
and dozens of trade deals trade deals
that many in the media said we would
never get uh she has delivered that she
has a very successful
manner about her when she's abroad and
engaging with people and i think that
success will transit from the
international trade department to the
foreign office
really well just just one last question
on the reshuffle we spoke to the
minister on the program yesterday about
it michael gove has been quoted as using
racist language specifically the term
fuzzy wuzzis and homophobic language in
a speech that he made admittedly some
years ago at the cambridge union now you
may all think this does not affect his
ability to remain in the cabinet but
isn't it about time we heard from
michael gove something of an apology for
the use of that language but i i didn't
get to university so uh but i do what i
read in the media university is uh well
obviously they do lots of uh interesting
things they have these debates where i
think that this was after they get they
get the cambridge union but well after
he was a stranger
the closest i got to cambridge i think
was a you know a visit a visit once i
mean i i
uh look i i think michael gave is one of
our most reforming
ministers he did an excellent job in
education you know my children's
education is better for his time at the
ministry of education and i think
on this story but look i don't
understand i have never known michael
gove to be shy of appearing on media
rounds he is very very good uh
formidable performer at it i'm sure you
can put those questions to him but
fundamentally i know michael he's not a
racist he's not homophobic in any way at
all he is in fact a great reforming
minister in this government and i i'm
actually very pleased that he's gone to
this department uh because we all need
some local government uh reforms and we
need to make sure that we start
delivering on a range of issues just in
terms of the the the repatriation of
people from afghanistan the afghan
citizens resettlement scheme what is the
latest on that we appear to be in a bit
of a holding position waiting for
negotiations to take between place
between ourselves unhcr
various ngos working in the region and
other international partners well so
remember there were three schemes
originally
one was british passport holders
entitled personnel
one was the arab scheme those are people
who'd effectively work directly or
indirectly through contractors for the
british ministry defense or indeed other
parts of the british government and then
there was the leave outside the rules
which were people such as
women
campaigners human rights campaigners
journalists lgbt community
that last group as you say have been uh
transferred into uh this new scheme
that's part of the 20 000
plus that we will be uh seeking to bring
here of course we have to manage some of
those people because they have to we
have to get them out of the country we
have to manage them either with the
taliban or indeed hopefully through
other third countries and that's what
we're in the process of doing
we have to manage it because we don't
want the third countries to shut their
borders and prevent them getting there
and we have to give them some
reassurances and we have to put in place
the right processes but you know what i
can say from my scheme the arap scheme
uh we are absolutely constantly in touch
with these people the people that were
called forward or eligible uh that's
some 263 plus their families we've
talked to
nearly all of them apart from about 40
odds that we haven't been able to get in
touch with and we keep trying and we
will do everything we can to continue to
support it as i've said all the way
along our app scheme is open it will
remain open we will repatriate them from
third countries we will bring some back
some of them have turned up in australia
some of them turned up in the united
states some of them turned up closer to
afghanistan and we are bringing them
back already minister good to see you
this morning thank you very much thank
you